Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
What he's done it,
Floyd Mayweather retires.
He's done the,
the thing that nobody ever does,
he went out on top undefeated with
all the money after having fought all
challengers.
I mean he might've fought pack out late,
but you can't deny that
he fought all challengers.
Who gives a fuck w I mean
the 50 things seems to be a,
an issue or not an issue.
40 to 50 now whether or not
he wants to break the record,
I mean,
well how much of that is,
is,
is the ego that's going to last for,
I mean he's still pretty young,
right?
Yeah.
I mean he's,
I think he's 36 if I had to guess,
but he's in really good shape.
I mean he takes care
of himself really well.
He's like notoriously disciplined about
workouts and he'll even go out at night,
go to a nightclub,
drink water,
and then work out at two o'clock in the
morning cause he has his own gym and his
own thing.
And you know,
he works hard.
You don't get that good on just talent.
You know,
you get that good on talent and
discipline and hard fucking work.
There's just no way around it and smart.
You gotta be smart too.
You gotta be sneaky.
You've gotta be clever.
Do you see,
uh,
who he is training right now for a fight?
Yeah.
He's a trained soldier.
Boy.
Soulja boy is really going
to fight Chris Brown.
Is that real?
I mean it doesn't seem like it,
but it's been talked
about for a few days now.
Apparently it's going to be on paper view,
um,
in fighting over a girl.
I don't,
I'm going to tell you right now,
Chris Brown's going to
fuck him up probably.
Yeah.
That's an angry dude.
But see,
that dude is on the left with the red.
That's a real angry dude.
The other dude,
I just do not think he is as angry
but ever known was man.
I've never seen either of them in person,
any one of them.
Maybe Soulja boy's been hide some sick
boxing skills and just pretending this
whole time.
I doubt it.
See,
I feel like Chris Brown is
probably punched a lot more people,
you know,
don't you think?
I don't know.
All,
you know,
wife beating girl beating jokes aside.
He's definitely seems like a dude who
is much more likely to punch people.
Um,
maybe,
maybe more likely to,
but I couldn't really see mo neither
either of them getting in like a street
fighter or anything.
They've been pretty famous for most
of their life and pretending to,
hmm.
Interesting.
Since they're in their teens,
um,
two guys,
shit happens.
So I mean they might have thrown
some darn down once or twice.
Oh,
Bill,
here's another thing.
Here's another reason
why I say Chris Brown.
Chris Brown's a real fucking dancer.
He ever see that guy move?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He could do some crazy shit.
He's really good in basketball.
Really good in basketball.
Listen,
this is going to be a blood bath.
I might be wrong.
What'd you buy it?
Yes.
Yeah,
I'll fucking buy it.
You know?
And if a soldier boy fucks him up,
I'll,
I'll apologize.
Have A,
I was trying to think about this.
Hasn't there been other things?
I mean,
I know you were supposedly
supposed to fight Wesley snipes,
but like wasn't there other
things like this ever happened?
I have a whole celebrity boxing show.
I remember that happened a couple.
Yeah.
Danny Bonaduce fought screech.
Um,
he fucked up a couple of people.
I remember when I was younger there
was supposed to be a big event where
Shaquille O'Neal was supposed to go one
on one on paper view with this other big
player named a camouflage one.
You're going to box not box.
They were going to come play basketball
one on one for me in dollars,
but it never ended up happening.
I don't know why and when went away,
but I was just kind of
wondering in my head like,
I feel like this has happened.
I've heard things like this
coming up and have like,
or at least been announced,
but they're just kind of fizzle out.
Who knows,
man.
I mean people have done crazy shit.
This just seems like a really,
really nutty one and they're
fighting over a girl.
I just,
I haven't seen any
evidence of soldier boy,
his athleticism.
He,
somebody put up a video
of him working out.
There's a compilation of him working out.
It's,
but it's hard to tell if
he's just being silly,
you know?
I was like,
he's a,
he's like shadow boxing and he's
riding an elliptical machine.
He seems like a really young guy.
How old is he?
Oh man,
this twenties still too.
He's in his twenties yeah.
Well,
there's,
there's a bunch of this
layer of complication.
Yeah.
This dude,
whoever they do that was narrated.
It was like,
oh man.
He goes,
you're working out with your socks on.
This is not the same compilation,
but it was pretty funny.
He's like,
only real savages.
Workout with their socks off.
I don't know,
man.
It's just w you know.
[inaudible].